este vehículo blindado ucraniano avanza
rápidamente por el campo de batalla en
las afueras de bahamut hace sólo unos
días los rusos ocuparon este territorio
estos soldados ucranianos recorren los
pocos kilómetros que según kiev han sido
recuperados
según los primeros informes la magnitud
de nuestro avance y el número de bajas
rusas es impresionante vale
algunos kilómetros de la línea de frente
estos soldados descansan en un búnker
subterráneo permanecen vigilantes Rusia
sigue controlando casi todo bajo mut los
recientes avances territoriales les dan
esperanzas el martes quien reivindicó la
liberación de unos 20 kilómetros
cuadrados al norte y al sur de las
afueras de bajomut
sabemos lo que estamos haciendo sabemos
cómo debemos atacar Cómo debemos
defendernos sabemos que al final del día
en dos tres o cinco años no lo sé
ganaremos esta guerra
en estas imágenes recibidas el martes el
comandante de las fuerzas terrestres de
Ucrania visita a los soldados que
combaten en la región de bahamut
no es acercarán a la victoria y nos
permitirán preparar a otros soldados que
participarán en la próxima ofensiva por
eso estamos muy agradecidos
ha sido el epicentro de los combates
durante meses Aunque la fecha de la
contraofensiva ucraniana sigue siendo
incierta estas tropas esperan con